we're on we're back what's up me and Sam
are here Sam but you wrote something at
the top of this I want to hear what you
have to say which is people's reply
about what we talked about last time
Gracia let's jump in with that all right
you wanna I'm gonna read just word for
word I have it pulled up on my Twitter
okay
you ready I'm not gonna read the guy's
name he goes I'm a modest-sized mid
seven-figure Amazon seller a network of
guys that range from 1 or 2 million to
probably 50 million plus we have a few
guys in our network that actually sold
their company to throw up well how do
you call it
gracias yeah they're a co happy to chat
about Amazon ecommerce sometime okay so
I'm gonna read his replies now for those
of you listening the background is is
that on Tuesday Sean and I talked about
the ratio it's a company that raised
money they raised one hundred two
hundred million at a 750 valuation I
don't remember yeah close to a hundred
million a dog - a big company you can
they're only tears old there and what
they're doing is buying Amazon
Fulfillment and filled by Amazon company
fulfilled by Amazon companies and they
are making the brands better and just
owning them they're doing a bunch of
stuff and so I had a guy reach out to me
and he I go that's great tell me what's
the I asked him what's the cash flow
situation like for most guys sub ten
million dollars they're probably working
with zero to a handful of US employees
still actively involved in the
day-to-day large team in the Philippines
and in cheap locations and are probably
netting between ten to twenty percent a
year and and so the typical size for
three to five million the typical size
is three to five million in revenue and
they're probably pulling in five hundred
to a million dollars a year for
themselves but the problem is is that
it's getting harder and harder in 2013
you could sell almost anything and scale
seven figure business now there are a
lot more dominant more sophisticated
players and it's incredibly hard to
enter in the business the Amazon
is much smarter and it makes ranking
incredibly expensive and difficult also
Amazon treats their sellers like trash
so it's kind of a mixed bag I could take
a month and do nothing and let my team
run it and it can go perfect or I can
get an email tomorrow saying my account
has been suspended or killed and I need
a lawyer to reinstate everything or I'm
just crushed so anyway Sean I wanted to
fill you in on this because I thought it
was cool inside I didn't know about yeah
that's that's a good insight so a couple
of thoughts on that so the first is I
think he's right you know back 2013-2014
it was a lot easier to do it than it is
today that seems consistent with what
I've heard in fact it seems like the
formula is build a successful Amazon
business in 2013 14 15 then start
teaching other people how to do it
because it's too hard to do anymore and
so now you start giving away the sort of
secrets and you become a teacher for the
next three years so I think that's the
the career path right now the other
thing that comes to mind we were talking
I was talking to Andrew Wilkinson about
this and he was saying he used the I
think it's a it's a Charlie Munger quote
which is it said Nassim Taleb quote
which is it's like picking up pennies in
front of a steamroller so the you know
there's a high probability you can make
a little bit of money um you know
consistently every single time you reach
down you pick it up and then there's you
know a low probability of complete death
and that's what he's talking about when
he says you can get a letter tomorrow
that says your account is suspended
goodbye and and that's it or Amazon cuts
the rates of your category like I have a
friend who was doing millions of dollars
of book sales as a third party book
seller on Amazon and the name was almost
like you know what
now our take rate on books has you know
not ten percent we're gonna do 25
percent things and that like killed that
happened to me this that happened to me
the other day
so in our via in the trends group
someone was like just so you know Amazon
changed the feet so basically I have
various blogs like my personal blog or
something like that
and it makes just like small amounts of
money like three to five thousand
dollars a month off Amazon affiliates
and I don't even check it it just runs
because because I write just written a
lot of content over the years gay
changed their rate and someone told me
in the group I think they I forget what
I was earning I don't even check it I
think I was earning 6% to 9% for a
affiliate revenue and then they changed
it to they like halved it so that money
just haft and it's no big deal because
it wasn't a it wasn't like a big income
stream for me but if you're a wire
cutter or if you're BuzzFeed and you
made a hundred million dollars from this
it's a huge deal right yeah that's what
that 20% cut makes it makes a really big
difference though it wasn't a it wasn't
a 20% cut it was way bigger than that it
was like half they have out and what
category are your links mostly and is it
electronics is it some cat is one
category was just across the board they
rate they lowered it across categories
but across the board it's close to half
my categories were probably personal
care and electronics I mean just anyone
who yeah or books a lot of books right
okay I want to know another topic so
we're good on Thor a CEO you want to add
anything else no you do not want to know
I think it's it's consistent with what
we thought you know I like when people
fill in the gaps with information that
we don't have right I'm not an FBA
seller I don't know the ins and outs of
that market I just think it's
interesting we talked a little bit about
it and then people fill in the gaps in
the next episode we come back a little
smarter that's a nice little formula we
have going so I appreciate that before
you ever talk about stuff you know tell
us tell us more about what you know that
we don't
before we go deep into serious stuff do
you want to talk about I want to give
you feedback that I got from from
listeners Sean you ready am I prepared
for this is this Harshal critical for
you that's good - okay great no ok so
what I'm noticing with this podcast is
we have a similar amount of views each
week and I think it's the same people
over and over I think we're like part of
people's routine which is cool and the I
think that one of the secrets to growing
a podcast is do you have to have guests
so when we had Andrew he shared it
that's all the people who like him came
and listened and I hope we've got him
hooked and they're gonna listen from now
on and so the way that we're gonna do
this is we're
to get more guests but here's what
people keep telling me and this they
weren't saying this about Andrew but
they like it when it's just you and I
rip in it and just make it [__] up on
the fly yeah yeah I felt that and I
think it's even more on these zoom calls
because the zoom called pace is a little
slower when we're in person it's a
little bit better I think to have that
third guest on the seat and it
definitely depends their guests got to
bring the bring to energy you can't just
be successful in smart that is not
enough you have to bring energy you got
to know what people want to hear about
and get to the point and so you know
that's the the rubric for guest which is
hard when you're also trying to find
famous guests because they help to show
grow and just for the record Sean and I
have recorded with I think we've done a
bunch of times I personally have done it
a bunch of times and it was wonderful
people who I like and it just turned out
to be bad and we just don't publish yeah
we throw it away and we don't even tell
we just throw it away
yeah and I've done it like four
throughout the years for whatever I
don't remember when I was recording
stuff for I've interviewed someone who
was like an amazing operator and the
content was wack and I'm like well trash
exactly so anyway the feedback that
we're getting someone is that people
like us because they say that I'm more
optimist and you're more like
down-to-earth and that we're if and they
love that and that they can't get that
anywhere but you and I are like let's go
get more guests and people don't like
the guess unfortunately that helps us
grow yeah well we'll keep mixing it in
dude I had a call yesterday that I was
like if I had just recorded this this
would have been like one of the dopest
podcasts ever it was just me and for a
con we have a call every once a week now
that's just called cool [__] and he
lives in like the edge of like
technology he's like in the dark web
basically that not in a legal way but
sort of like he's on the forefront of
what's interest like an he's just a nerd
he's just like a very typical Silicon
Valley engineer just yeah he knows a
reality a good way he knows me well
enough and also he loves money enough
where he knows how to take that stuff
and bubble up the bits that are
interesting the bits that are relevant
and not just getting lost in the weeds
of
Knology so that comet was amazing but
unfortunately to record the other thing
I was gonna say about the guests is
being guests on other people's podcast
is the other way to grow so I had he
Sean let yesterday reach out to like 50
podcasts and just be like hey I'll go on
and talk about it right like I'll go on
I just sold my company I can go on and
talk about that hey we built a podcast
that did a million downloads in the
first six months we could talk about how
we did that and so I think guesting on
other people's podcast might be a good
way you did this with Gary Vee with pomp
so yeah I probably so there's a caveat
there I've I've probably been a guest a
hundred times and there was a period
like over the trailing six months I have
it set on my calendar from 3 o'clock to
5 o'clock that's only guessing a podcast
and I would do it and some of the small
ones just drove nothing right like it
was total hit or miss and so I would
spend like three weeks doing it and it's
almost like and you probably like this
it's like being the comedian you just
say the same [__] over and over and you
kind of figure out what hits and it's
fun it's almost like therapy you just
talk about yourself it's cool but it
definitely gets a little repetitive and
it the results are not always there but
they are sometimes yeah and you know the
thing you said at the beginning which is
for podcasting you get this base and
it's the sticky sticky base of people
who want to listen to it all the time it
becomes a part of the routine they start
to really love you that sort of thing
it's very different than other products
I built where I'm like alright I want to
get millions of users to just visit this
page or like just use this once a week
or subscribe to this and kind of forget
about it like that's been a lot of the
products I built this is the opposite
it's like an army of a hundred thousand
people who will like go to war for you I
think there's people in this group that
would if I said hey I need you to beat
this person up they would go beat that
person up like there's people who really
have your back and when I started this I
remember I was talking to Sully who's
the very first guest on the pod and he
was like you know what do you think it
makes you just sold the company and I
was like you know I really like this
podcast thing it was okay like is that a
business like in some ways it's a step
down right it's like I'm gonna wait way
less doing this than I did my last
business or any other business I want to
do and I was like look I want to just be
in like a million people's ear
every morning if I did that I just know
that that's a good thing and I don't
know how to get there but I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna get into a million
people's ear balls every morning on
their way to work and the way to work I
think that's powerful yeah I mean it may
or may not be a business but it
definitely will lead to way more
opportunity yeah I've had a lot of I
mean I've been doing the content thing a
little bit like before the podcast so I
kind of understand it but the podcast
definitely is different I remember I
went to New York salon and I just
tweeted I was like I'm we're gonna be
over I'm gonna be over here because I
was there for a hustle advertising crap
and I just tweeted as like yeah I want
to be here I had 200 people want to come
and so we only let maybe 20 come and
because we're in people's a years dude
like these people this kid Ryan said
something to me and he's like yeah you
know cuz you said how much you like this
thing and I was like I don't remember
what you're talking about and like if
they think they know you and you know
they are like is that people or the
people who is this our actual pretty
really really smart and successful you
know I think a lot of podcasts that are
about business they cater to kind of
lowest common denominator so it's like
oh the waltrip renewer is their core
market and you know in our Facebook
group for this podcast I posted
something saying hey I'm doing something
cool for people who have a business that
does over a million dollars a year and
there's like a hundred plus replies just
in that Facebook group of people who
have businesses doing over a million
dollars a year right so these are not
like kind of like the want reproduce you
know at their nine-to-five job or a
college kid or something like that like
of course there are people like that but
the audience also is mixed with a lot of
interesting successful people there's a
bunch of VCS that listen to this it's
crazy
so anyways enough about the podcast
let's give people some some other topics
or ideas Allen says my video looks good
now and yeah one other thing you have
you kind of have the mic to the side of
your mouth and when you turn so your
voice goes in and out so just keep it
like just talk directly into the mic
let's talk one more thing about the
podcast which is my house looks like
it's crazy right now I had to go and buy
this mic I've at it like to set this all
up dude it's been so hard to set up like
a zoom thing and it's hard I hate this
yeah I know you want you want that
business to exist which is push a button
give me like a dope podcast like turnkey
yes oh and for anyone who's listening
this is podcast related a little bit I
promise I'll finish up with this but
this is awesome so my friend Neville
Medora he sponsored last podcast
copywriting course calm I plugged him he
I did like a happy hour with him I mean
I don't know and dinner where we just
were just shoot the [__] because we
haven't been able to see each other
because this stuff he use a DSLR as his
webcam and it was awesome it was so easy
it looks amazing it made him look like a
Greek god it looks like he's like it's
all like it's like does that I don't
know about cameras where it does like
you're blurry in the background it gets
cold like this bouquet or something like
that so so I saw on YouTube there's this
guy Gary tan he's an investor in Silicon
Valley he's like yeah one of the Y
Combinator partners and he did this
YouTube video that was like how to look
like a [__] amazing on zoom and I was
like dude this makes sense this is the
new like this is the equivalent of
wearing a suit to work down right like
yeah hang on zoom and not looking like
[__] with your room looking like [__]
and so this video only had 1500 views
but he's like look this is the camera I
used this is the mount this is the lens
here's how you get the that blurred
background look and like he looks
amazing and then when I saw that photo
you'd the screenshot your head of Nevel
I was like I bet you he watched that
video and there was only 1500 views but
I was like anybody who's watching this
and the other guy who who did it was a
Neve drawer who's the founder of he was
that product now unit Shrunk capital and
he does it too and it really doesn't
look amazing and what I saw that I was
like I should do this I should so I was
gonna do it I didn't know about this
video last night I bought $700 for the
stuff I bought so I already have these
Phillips you light bulbs know what those
are
yep yep where you I just say Alexa turn
the lights on right there like smarsh
yeah it's gonna turn the lights on so I
bought those but you see back here
behind the couch I'm gonna put them
there and so it's gonna like shoot up
and I hope it's so like I we have like a
room oh wait I forgot I'm not using the
camera we have a room clean anyway
you'll see it so I'm into aemond on this
I like it so this guy reached out from
Twitter who he's done a couple of
e-commerce things that are kind of
interesting and so I was talking to him
and he
his new thing so he's basically he
initially was targeting twitch streamers
because he's like look when you're a
streamer you're basically broadcasting
from your bedroom and streamers invest
in all this like artwork cool lights
wall panels smart speakers all this
stuff to make the room look good and
he's like I'm gonna make an e-commerce
store that's like just gonna do that
look at all
I'll find the name of it I don't know if
he wants me to kind of out him so we may
have to believe this if if he's not into
it but I'll say it right here it's
called visual candy and this guy's smart
I like this guy a lot and so said it was
but now with the work from home I think
this extends a lot past where his
initial market was which is youtubers
and twitch stars and now it's you know
any professional who's gonna spend some
amount of time in a home office and just
think about the amount of home offices
that are being built out right now
because people are needed infrastructure
for this but that's gonna stick around
once kovat goes away yeah I have loved
I'm really into it I've like gone to
Amazon and I've tried buying like all
the stuff and it's it's kind of
complicated because I didn't know which
batteries do this I was like how do I
just I was like where does the camera
need to be so I'm doing this there's
another thing called a cam link I just
looked this up it's got Oh makes it
Elgato yeah and it I went and looked at
it and it was they built this entire
thing for streaming for gamers and it
looks awesome I'm gonna I definitely go
to start buying this stuff I'm probably
gonna drop two grand on all this crap um
I think we'll turn our but we have
another bedroom I'll turn that into an
office so I'm I like all this crap dude
I love buying [__] when you buy and when
I just get on a buy streak and I'm like
yeah you know what I deserve this
I need that and like you know what's the
problem here and and actually buying
stuff is not I don't know there's
something like cathartic about it like
just the act of buying it feels [__]
great and I love it yeah but for me I've
been having a call 1-800 junk and having
to spend like if I buy like a new desk
the boxes are so big I gotta pay $100
just a box problem is insane
especially here in San Francisco the box
problems insane I [__] hate it I hate
it it's one of the reasons why I moved I
live in a house now I used to live in a
building and one of the reasons was is
because I didn't have to worry about the
trash right well but no matter how much
space I have because I thought oh I got
this new house I was like now have a
garage I got this like tradesman Ally I
got this extra closet but it's that same
principle I think it's like the
Parkinson's law or whatever which is
time will work will expand to fill the
time you give it so let's say you have a
week to do the project guess what it's
gonna take you a week if you had a day
to do that same project you would have
only taken you a day and in the same way
like junk your [__] will expand to fill
the space you have and so here let me
let I've thought about this a lot let me
get wise here okay I'm a amateur
beekeeper so I have bees do you know
this no you know this okay
sure how they don't have your bees the
right now so they actually went away but
since 2013
I've kept bees so I've always for the
most part so listen I'll tell you all
about this for the most part in my lot
in my San Francisco life for 10 years
I've lived in Glen Park it's a nice
neighborhood in San Francisco it's like
residential no and I've always had a
backyard and I wanted a hobby that was
not expensive and I didn't want it to
turn into a business and I just wanted
something fun that I could be outside
and I made a list of hobbies that I
could pick and pick the lamest one and
top because it doesn't cost a lot of
money to start if you want to you can
just leave it alone and not do anything
or if you wanted to you could poke
around with it and like be active with
it so low maintenance low maintenance it
does it only cost three to five hundred
dollars to get into the Hobby you don't
have to buy a bunch of [__] to keep up
with it and it was allowed me to be
outside and so I became a beekeeper in
2013 I think and so how do bees live
like do somebody that's around from then
no no no they make I think they might
only live for like a few months they
cycle through and so I bought about
10,000 bees and I get honey from and I
just give it away and I I caught
southern Sam sticky icky and and so I've
had bees for years and when
lived in Soma i only live in someone for
a year and then I went back to Glen Park
and I just kept it on the roof at my
office so you can have bees I would have
10 10 thousand bees just on the roof of
our office and no one would know they
say to themselves mostly and they go out
and get honey or it get pollen and they
turn it to a nectar and it turns into
honey and anyway but here's the
interesting thing that I learned see
this has been like this is my board the
wisdom comes like here's the interesting
things that I've learned with bees as
bees fill the space that they are given
with honey so if you give them a lot of
space
they will always fill it if you don't
give them a lot of space then they just
won't make it right so it's the rule
little sticky icky and so I've learned
this through bees that humans are the
same way if you give them a lot of space
then they will fill it with a ton of
stuff if you give them not a lot of
space
they just won't buy stuff you just won't
you just won't get stuff and so that's
the important thing so when you think of
like I'm gonna get this huge house so
I'll have a ton of room and I'll have
more space you're gonna fill it to the
brim with crap and you will no longer
have space it always works okay that's
amazing I love that story didn't know
you were beekeeper I've known you for
like six years I had no idea by the way
we both studied abroad in Sydney and I
took a class because when you study
abroad you're trying to have a good time
you're not trying to learn and so I took
the easiest class I could find which was
a bee a bee class and so I learned all
this [__] about bees and bees have some
crazy things like just too quick be
facts if I remember correctly from ten
years ago I learned that when a when the
queen bee goes to mate she leaves on an
expedition and she will mate with as
many male bees as she can along the way
and she basically has sex with them and
then kills them right after which breaks
their back and they die and then she
sort of it gets impregnated by all these
bees and then there's this other thing
which is really interesting that that
people have learned from bees which is
like a big evolutionary learning which
was in a bee hive many of the bees could
be fertile but they choose to be sterile
and they choose to just take care of the
queen bees kids because they're all
related by like some 25 they're all like
quarter sisters or something like that
they're all like 25% related and it
turns out like in a Darwinian sense you
are better your genes are better off so
if you just take ten to these
half-sisters and quarter sisters that
you have rather than trying to have your
own kids and survive and so that's the
crazy thing about bees bees are awesome
man it's a great hobby you can get into
it for two or fifty dollars all you got
to do is go to Amazon and you type in
beekeeping kit and someone will send you
the kit and then you go on your critical
Craigslist you might even be able to buy
them online but that might take like a
few weeks but if you go on your local
Craigslist you type in bees there's a
farmer nearby but you can pay $100 and
they'll give you 10,000 bees and they'll
set it up for you it's so it's super
easy to get into and it is so fun bees
you could eat I get [__] I mean I'll get
like I kind of think about this like
probably five to eight gallon milk jugs
like what's the how BIG's a bug is that
a gallon of milk yeah like that that
worth a honey maybe five to eight a year
they're introducing okay cool lots of
money also related to this idea of like
people buy stuff and people love stuff
and people fill their space with stuff
and bees will fill their space with
stuff if you want a good five minutes go
on YouTube and type Chris D'Elia girls
love things and you will have a great
time for five minutes
okay and now that brings TV to a random
startup idea so I don't think this would
work so let me start with that but
there's something interesting here we're
so Netflix recently left hooks in the
last few years started going heavy into
comedy so comedy used to be like HBO
kind of owned the space where they would
do you know HBO specials and then that
kind of dried up and comics are like
cockroaches they'll always survive it's
like okay we'll go play in the dingy
estroux meeee we'll go on stage we'll
get it Netflix special we'll get HBO
special okay we're back to the dark room
again like they won't quit because
they're like degenerates and now
podcasting has been a huge boom for them
so Chris D'Elia who also just had a
Netflix special come out these guys make
tons of money right so Netflix started
cutting like 10 20 million dollar checks
I believe to these comedians because
they know that comedians have these like
rabid followings and the content is good
it's unique sort of proprietary content
but I think that there's a product out
there sort of like a crunchy
crunchyroll did for anime I think
somebody could do for the mid-tier
comedians I think you can make a sort of
$5 a month $7 a month subscription to
the comedians that are not going to get
met flick specials right so not Chris
Rock and not Seinfeld and Chappelle and
and all those guys but like the next
teardown like even you know one level
below like the Whitney Cummings of the
world right because they are still
getting Netflix specials and I think you
could add them up and it doesn t want to
be the hour-long special it could be
like a 10-minute set set or a 20-minute
set or something like that and I think
you could get I think each of them have
a few thousand fans that would pay to be
able to access that exclusive comedy
content and and so you would act if you
just aggregate all the comedians then
it's a sort of all-you-can-eat pass
where as a viewer I can discover other
comedians too
so anyways I think that there's a
business potentially for a mid-level
Netflix for comedians where you
aggregate them what do you think great
I'm looking up information so I can
my brains rolling and I'm gonna let me
let me tell you what I think so
first of all kwibi I imagine it's trying
to do something that so kwibi is that
even [__] how you say yeah it's
pretty stupid I mean look I think with
kwibi
it actually can be great because the
people who are running it are like super
smart but it does not look like a good
bet now but it still might be anyway
they're trying to do something like that
second I think that that is a great idea
and I think the way that I would find
out how to do it is I would look up
quelle au q e ll Oh have you heard of
Cuomo I've never heard of it okay hello
is is it's a it's I think it was started
way before its time it's an app on Apple
TV and all they have is live concerts
and so it was started in 2010 and it's
available and it's like a it's a app for
your phone but I think it's best on
Apple TV and you could download it and
you pay ten thousand or because it may
be ten dollars a month and sometimes
does about Elizabeth I think it's ten
dollars a month and you just get access
to a library of live concerts have you
ever wanted to do that or is
just me I kind of do this on youtube but
YouTube like has enough free like I
listen to a bunch of like Red Rocks
concerts right cuz there's a concert
venue called Red Rocks which is awesome
and like anytime I musician goes there
they film it in like epic with epic
cameras and sound and they're just like
available on YouTube for free but this
is cool I like this it's awesome and
it's it's better than YouTube but
YouTube is great and the reason it's
better is because like if you buy like a
concert DVD the camera works a little
bit better and the sound is a lot better
and I love live music and so I am a big
fan of this and they have 70,000 paying
subscribers they were recently acquired
by stingray communications which is a
publicly traded company in Canada it's a
cable company so if I were you Sean and
I wanted to launch this or if I was a
listener I wanted to launch this I would
look up stingray communication and I
would go and read the the filing for
that company and I would figure out
exactly what quello does that's what I
would do and I would learn about how
they did it because it's a relatively
niche thing they only have 70,000
subscribers it's not huge and they've
been at it for 10 years so it's not a
big number and I think it is incredibly
viable business and I think it's great
another thing another thing that I would
do is I would look up Discovery Channel
and then National Geographic are you
familiar familiar with National
Geographic or obviously right ok
National Geographic is still a huge
company in Disney recently bought into
it at a billion dollar valuation it may
still make they still make hundreds of
thousands or hundreds of millions of
dollars a year from their magazine
subscription is that crazy
and so I would put date but here
National Geographic was a non-profit and
and so the good thing about nonprofits
is you can go to see all the numbers and
so what I would go and look at I would
look at discovery and I would look at
mass National Geographic and I was look
at koala and I would see what they are
doing because those are relatively niche
subscription companies that crush so
long story short great idea
okay cool all right what else we got you
wanted to talk about this card I think
yeah so I am a user Carta
I think the products only okay it's
still quite frustrating to use but Carta
laid off a bunch of people the other day
more than 67 people
yeah and they raised money and their CEO
Henry wrote this message that he made
public and he said something like it was
not your man managers fault for laying
you off it was 100% my fault in fact it
was the opposite your managers tried to
help you and I'm on the one who reviewed
every list and I said we're gonna fire
this person so blame me and I think that
was great I thought it was a great
message so so high level he was
basically saying hey we laid a bunch of
people off and I'm going to publish the
announcement I made to the company so
that you know presumably other CEOs and
other companies can kind of learn from
this use this or take solace in the fact
that I did this - I don't know whatever
yeah
content marketing and he published this
and I typically and fall into the
category of all press is good press go
ahead and do it I thought this was kind
of lame did you do you agree and and I
and I tweeted that Henry and I want him
to come here and I'll say this to his
face
I think he seems like a cool guy this
move I think was kind of lame right I
would agree I've kind of followed this
guy for a little while like I've read
some of his other stuff we're seeing
some interviews seems like a good guy
seems like a smart guy and I think
Carter is a good product and I like some
of the other stuff they've done like
they have a next chapter program
basically to help people who want to
people want to leave the company they
don't make it this like awkward exit
they like celebrate it and whatever you
know in theory so I thought this was
lame mostly because I thought two things
I thought it was tone-deaf and secondly
I didn't think the actual statement was
very good so I thought oh just a part
the premise of what he was trying to do
like what is the upside and what is the
downside it to me it looked like he was
trying to Pat himself on the back and I
know he would he would say that's not
what I'm trying to do blah blah I think
I was trying to Pat himself on the back
and also like you know give a little bit
of sort of you know put card his name
out there again like just like it's kind
of like the buffer wave like publish
everything and the good the bad the ugly
and you get attention but I just thought
it was tone-deaf and also it seemed like
what he wanted people's reaction to be
was like wow great leadership way to
take responsibility great CEO ship and
he got that and both not from me when I
read this
I was like this was a pretty horrible
way to do the announcement and I'll tell
you why he started okay so here's like
I'm just gonna bullet point the the
summary so he goes over the last few
weeks we're talking about recession
planning
I said layoffs were likely and today is
the day I can't delay it any longer okay
weird start but alright then he says I'm
sorry if I apologize if I sound robotic
I'm reading off a script because I don't
know if I could get through this without
something to lean on
okay you're not the victim don't say
that that's also kinda yeah that that's
pretty late yeah blame is [__] then he
says okay let me start with the details
we're gonna lay off 161 employees that's
16% of our company it's gonna be
different across the company all right
whatever then this was weird I thought
it was just like if you heard one of
those affected you'll receive an
invitation from your manager if you do
not receive a meeting invitation you are
safe and I was like okay Hunger Games a
little odd way to do it but you know in
a zoom world I don't know if there is a
better way to really like kind of mass
do this where you can't have the
information come out until it needs to
come out but I just thought like it's
anxiety that's a very like anxious
feeling thing and also you got to know
if you're the CEO and you say that
people's minds just start racing in that
direction they're just imagining what
the next hour of their life is gonna be
they're not even gonna hear the next
three paragraphs you say like their mind
is gone they checked out it's thinking
about themselves and said whatever the
next three paragraphs are ignore it so
then he goes alright the moral conflict
this is the part I thought was wack so
he's like in a couple of town halls ago
I said there was two perspectives around
layoffs the first of the shareholder
perspective we're reducing costs and
protecting cash or what matters the
second is the employee perspective with
nothing matters more than saving jobs
and helping employees in a you know in a
time where it's like unemployment at
levels of the Great Depression so each
of these are clear they're unambiguous
and they're correct from their
perspective but they are diametrically
opposed this creates a conundrum for CEO
CEO sit between shareholders employees
and wish that they could do both for
every CEO they have to deal with this
conflict I chose to manage this conflict
by taking the shareholder perspective in
deciding who should leave and take the
employees backed it on how to help to me
I was like what is this paragraph like
dude yeah what the [__] dude it's all
the same
you're just trying to build a company
that makes profit and does work with
good people that's the same thing yeah
and like think about you have to think
about your audience do you think your
audience gives a [__] about the
shareholder perspective and the dilemma
you have as a CEO and how you've chose
to straddle this as a CEO it's not even
about you so I just thought this was the
part that was really odd to me that like
see it seemed like he I don't know I
wouldn't have included this in the
statement and I thought that this made
it look quite bad and I would not want
other CEOs emulating this part of the
statement because what matters is your
audience as your employees and you need
to know hey this is really hard for us
we tried to analyze every situation cut
every other dollar we could before we
cut anyone's jobs and we did that but
this is the this is the path we have to
go you know this is I'm terribly sorry
like I did not manage the company in a
way where we had enough buffer this is a
failing on my part this is the worst you
know the worst day in my my time as a
company and it is for all of us and so
like here's what this means for you and
like all you have to say is like this
sucks
we tried everything we could do this was
the last resort and you know here's how
we're gonna make it right by you and not
like this theory about how shareholder
value matters and the CEO has to like
straddle these things it's like yeah I I
think that and I think that that's not
only does nobody care I think that that
is just a silly way to look at it which
is when you're building a company like
step one is create something that people
want and get it and get it into the
hands get it into their hands in a
profitable way okay that's step one like
that that is just the the that's the
basics of a company which is you make
something that someone wants to give you
money or you make something and you make
a profit off of it right and if I was I
don't think that's step one but that is
the fundamental premises that's the
fundamental that's a fundamental
premises what I mean
and so if I was him I'd be like look
here's the deal like we expect we expect
it to grow a lot faster and we're
investing in this and the plan would
have worked but this thing slowed
everything down and so we just have to
cut things that are not profitable right
and that sucks and I'm sorry that that
sucks but that's what's going to happen
and
think that if you just say that and a
more straightforward way instead of all
this shareholder value [__] like you
already know that you know they're all
adults in the room to understand this
[__] crazy virus is happening in
companies across the board or having
trouble some companies have no revenue
now like people get that that that's
happening and it's just like okay so
what's gonna happen at our company Oh at
our company we they tried everything
they could they're making the sort of
this is what do you need to say was this
was our last resort we did this in a way
where we're not gonna have another round
of layoffs because that creates you know
I wouldn't say that I would I would say
we're gonna try not to yeah like you
know that is our goal and how we did
this but even then that's speaking to
the people who are staying you know
really at this point you just have to
speak to the total group and just say
some of you gonna be affected here's how
it works
here's how we're doing our best to to
make it right to do right by everybody
who's done right by us this is no fault
of your own this is a fault of ours in
running a company that was not did not
have the margin of error to do yeah I
think that like what I would just say if
I had to do this which I hope I never
have to but me I probably really will
have to one day not like I'm saying our
company but well I'm not implying
anything I'm just saying what if I have
if I have a long career which I will
that you gotta say look I have a hundred
percent of the flock that I have to
manage and take care of and sometimes
that might mean that I have to fire 30%
of the flock in order to take care of
the other sixty and that it's just how
life works and this just sucks
and I'm trying to make this hat in such
a way that the 40% are not completely
hung out to dry but this is just what I
have to do and I'm sorry that this is is
the situation and if you want to blame
someone blame me and that's that and
that's pretty much all you have to say
yeah exactly like you don't need the the
epic speech and you know right now we're
kind of like look I think we're clear
that hey personally for us this didn't
like come across great and we weren't
like oh wow that was epic on the other
side you know we're just kind of off the
cuff coming up with what a what a better
speech might be but the reality is that
in this case they
you basically have a speechwriter you
have a multi-bit you have a
billion-dollar company and you have time
to think about this and this is the what
we're reading is his output after
thinking about it and so that's the part
that I thought was also I wouldn't have
published it I want to publish this
because it's like you take this [__] it
take this on the chin like and by the
way I know I'm criticizing this guy I
don't know him he and I will tell us -
I'll say this to his face and I'm sure
he's actually a good good dude this is
just a big Mis but I would say like dude
you got to take this one on the chin and
just like this is a loss and and say be
a man and say what you want to say to
your people which that's your fault
that's wonderful
I wouldn't publish this agreed I didn't
understand that and also I'm not sure
yeah I'm not sure what the with this
world upside of was of that was now on
the other hand I think they did
something's great right so like the
actual actions that they were taking it
for people I thought were great they're
like look we're gonna extend the Cobra
health insurance till the end of the
year because health insurance is super
important especially right now and so
they didn't have to do that but they did
they remove people's cliff and they
invested their shares that didn't have
to do that but they did you know they
they gave them I think about a bit of
severance didn't after that but they did
and then they have this sort of alumni
network where they're trying to help
people get jobs cool I like all of that
like I liked all of that action I just
didn't like the preamble and I didn't
like the sort of pat on pepper seemed a
little bit like pat me on the back
please can I show you my leadership
during this adverse time so you could
like get tell me I did a good job and
that's the part I didn't like I liked a
lot of the action yeah and like you I
don't know this guy so you know this is
not no no personal thing again I I have
friends who work with them and I've
heard a lot of positive stuff I just
think that like and III value
I applaud Cardiff for raising this money
and going big and trying to make
something happen and I plod them from
over for over hiring in hopes of like it
working like I I applaud the risk-taking
and I want people who are listening that
just because Sean and I are criticizing
this guy you got to take risk still and
you got to try this big [__] and it's
not gonna work all the time good I mean
not good but like whatever that's just
you got it comes with the territory and
I just wouldn't she would have took it
on the chin a little bit more
right okay I got another one more topic
that's on a more positive note okay so
I'm gonna wash I feel like I got a had
some haterade spilled on me there I
gotta wash that off yes by the way but
Ron you and I typically are I'm rarely a
hater
exactly we're rarely haters no I really
like yeah so I want to end this by
saying I hope these guys crush it I hope
they do wonderful I believe I think they
actually will I just think that this one
move was a stupid move and probably a
very long and positive journey right and
and look you know there's a big
difference of criticizing a person
versus criticizing an action or
criticizing a you know something that
was done and this is definitely like you
didn't like the message not the dono
don't even know the messenger can we
just say by the way that a lot of people
in media like in who have these podcasts
and newsletters and they're all [__]
haters of the people they're covering
it's not about the craziest thing ever
yeah well I think it's like it's like a
fair trade so so there's a guy Eric
Weinstein have you heard this guy's
podcast yes I like it it's called the
portal smart guy I don't know too much
about him he runs like Peter Till's fund
and so he's been talking about this
concept lately
that's called kayfabe have you heard him
talking about this no okay so he's like
hey there's this wrestling term called
kayfabe ka y fa b and he's like what
kayfabe is is like you know in wrestling
it's basically wrestling is a fake fight
right WWE it's like a pre-arranged sort
of agreed-upon fake fight where I'm the
hero and you're the heel or I'm the good
and you're the bad whatever and in it
it's like the dialogue is sort of an
agreed fight for both of our betterment
like the more we feud the more popular
we both become and the fight itself like
okay we agree sort of agree to do this
and so he talks about how this happens
in the real world too like right now I
see this whenever Trump goes and does
his briefing and then there's that one
guy from CNN gym off cost I think is his
name
yeah and he's always there and he
Trump's like okay yeah you're next
and it he asked this question and Trump
like rips him and then that becomes like
the seven-minute YouTube clip and CNN
talks about it all day and like you know
on one hand it's like why doesn't Trump
just kick this guy out or like you know
remove revoke his press you know
credentials here on the other hand why
doesn't this other guy you know either
you know fight back or start or like
take some other action every day the
same sort of thing plays out and I think
in reality it serves them both extremely
well where CNN gets awesome content that
people want to watch because it's juicy
to see the president fight with somebody
and Trump also loves the attention on
the left on the right good and bad and
then he drums it up as dude those
liberals are always trying to say this
and then the right supports him more
because he has an enemy that's attacking
right and so there's like this dance
that they're doing so I get that and I
get that but here's what I don't get so
I'll give you a very specific example
this pissed me off so much there's this
woman named the Natasha t22 I forget
what a Natasha - I don't know how to
pronounce my last name I forget it
though it's like his anyway she was a
blogger for Valleywag
which Valleywag was pretty funny and all
but they took it too far
all they did was made fun of Silicon
Valley and then she worked at BuzzFeed
and then Wired magazine and now she's at
Washington Post and she had this article
that says Silicon Valley now deems
luxury housing and essentials and
essential good good and so people are
still building multi-million dollar
condos and in the first [__] line of
the article it says the mayor has deemed
luxury housing as well as all other
types of housing including including
housing projects and this other stuff as
essential and it was in the technology
section of the Washington Post yeah here
is Natasha - tea - yeah Tiku tik you and
I've better before and and I was like
what the [__] that's like saying like
I'm gonna write an article in TechCrunch
and be like can you believe this
billionaires are able to buy 1 million
dollar cars and then in the article
humble
but also anyone can buy any car
including a $1,000 Mazda
including a $20,000 Honda Civic
including a $50,000 Mercedes I think
what and then why is it in the tech
section of Washington Post oh my god
this pisses me off and so I looked this
woman up and she's very educated she
went to NYU and then like Columbia
Journalism or like just like Ivy League
just really smart woman and I'm like why
would you study for eight years or
however long it took and spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars when you're just
gonna to do this hey you're just gonna
hate the people who you write about I
don't understand it why not just go and
write about something that like who you
want to celebrate of course they'll say
we don't hate them we're just you know
we're reporting on that we're reporting
the stories we don't have we don't hate
them so there was a really interesting
thing that happened recently where for
coronavirus there's this guy Balaji
who's on Twitter pretty popular guy he
was at Andreessen Horowitz a bunch of
stuff there's a coin base and things
like that so he's kind of one of those
like on the forefront of things guys so
back in January he showed up at a crypto
Meetup he was wearing gloves and a mask
and this was January when nobody in the
US was really worried about this and
everyone's kind of laughing like what
are you doing he's like well you know I
think that's just a you know you know
maybe small probability but that this
coronavirus thing that's happening in
Wuhan is gonna be like a major you know
global pandemic and people okay
Balaji all right thanks and so this
writer came out and about box bought the
Vox of RICO writer yeah so Rico
Dreamcoat oh my god this imperious me so
the quick story here is the recode rider
reaches out to Paulo G and says like hey
I want to get your comment on a story
we're doing about you know Silicon
Valley's reaction to the corona virus
this was again early on and he was like
yeah I'm not interested why don't you
report on like who cares about Silicon
Valley's what the Silicon Valley elite
think about coronavirus like you should
report on the state of testing the state
of the the you know the spread of the
virus and all these other like kind of
like important facts that should be
reported on and he tweeted out that he
did that that happened he screenshotted
heard E
and tweeted it and then all the
journalists were like dude she was just
asking for comment why are you putting
on blast this is why people hate Silicon
Valley and he was like no no no I know
this game and he so he talked about this
he's like this is a strategy called
befriend and betray where the journalist
comes to uses hey Balaji you're an
expert I would love to get your take on
this thing and all they're trying to do
is write the story and what the headline
of the story came out was something
along the lines of like you know why
Silicon Valley's not doing handshakes
anymore and it was like laughing at
Silicon Valley sort of for overreacting
to the corona virus this was early on
before all the long time he said he goes
I promise you the headlines gonna be
right lookin Valley nerds refused to
shake hands and I never what it was
pretty much what it was now the body of
the article I went back and read it was
actually you know somewhat fair was just
reporting what was going on how whatever
but he was right about the headline and
the headlines often written not by the
journalist but by the editor cuz editor
need to drive clicks blah blah blah
anyway so this is pretty interesting
feud if you want to hear more the Jason
Calacanis did a podcast apology that I
thought was pretty awesome so I can't I
can't stand that at particularly given
like me like people always like oh
you're a tech bro and the odd some
journalists will say that I'm like you
work at Vox if I'm tech so are you like
what does that mean like like I have a
journalist in New York Times come and
interview me she's like so what do you
and you're like tech bro friends talk
about yeah I was gonna ask you to do
this so tell the story your New York
Times story this is an amazing story
you've told me yeah so first of all like
I made sure I recorded it in a head
because I knew so I knew that this
person was gonna take me out of context
what was the context you went to New
York or no she came here she goes hey
you seem like an insider I want to come
and learn all the things that people are
gonna are talking about befriend yeah
and I go okay fine come I know what
you're doing come on and but maybe it
could be positive like maybe we'll
become like we can exchange cool
information maybe you'll write something
positive about me maybe I'll just
whatever it may be it'll turn out good
and she comes she goes can I record this
I go yeah I'm gonna record it too and
and because I didn't want anything to be
taken out of context and she goes so
like you're like a tech bro like what do
you and your tech friends
talk about and your bro-friends and I
was like first of all why are you
calling me a bro like it what are you
and your tech chick friends like why
would you ever say that to me you don't
know me and that's just rude to say
anyway and I and she I go well I don't
know you I go your attack you tell me
she goes no I work at New York Times I
was like you guys just announced that
most of your revenue comes from digital
like Europe why am i tech and you're not
tax like you are attacking Jews well
it's just different I was like well you
tell me what you you you and your tech
friends talk about and she goes well
we're not what ever she like reddit I
was like anyway I go well we talk about
uh just like you know sports and I was
like I don't know we just talk about
normal stuff like cool diets or like
cool food like all types of weird stuff
and it was just so odd she was just so
trying to like it was so much like an
other like I am an other from you and
I'm like I don't I don't understand this
this this this dichotomy here like we
are actually in the same industry I work
in publishing so do you we both make
most of our money from the internet like
why are you calling me this tech bro I
you don't even know me and she's like
what you don't listen to Joe Rogan do
you I'm like well yeah I do I listen to
a lot of cool stuff I I read and this is
true every morning I go to CNN and then
I go to Fox News and then I go to HuffPo
and then I go to break part because
those are all like kind of the opposite
I read all types of stuff I like to
orokin I like Oprah I do all types of
stuff why are you trying to like set me
up for this gotcha moment right and it
was horrible I hated it and so to sum
this up the headline by the way we have
it multi-million dollar mansions
high-rise waterfront condos and a
stately Victorian all deemed quote
essential under public health orders in
San Francisco and Silicon Valley that
was the headline and then in the first
paragraph it said it said restated the
headline and then added as well as
housing projects and low-income housing
all deemed essential right oh my god I
can't stand it I'm like why would you I
love those we bought when we bought Bebo
back so we had bought Bebo from me
out of an auction and we were gonna
relaunch it as something and so nobody
knew that we had bought it back it was
like done in a court room was like kind
of on the low and there was a new
reporter and we you know we were kind of
friendly I guess we had friends of
friends that were mutual and so I was
like okay hey you know I want to give
you a scoop and you know on the embargo
and like come to an interview and
whatever so she was like great comes
over doesn't an interview explain the
whole thing where you talk about what
we're doing blah blah blah
next day the article comes out and this
is the person we gave the scoop to we
could have given it anyone next day
article comes out headline was remember
Bebo yeah that'd be but it was like it
was something like you know remember
Bebo yeah it's dead but maybe you know
it was like something like Bebo is dead
remember Bebo literally it was like lol
was like in the headline it was like
making fun of and then the whole article
was our conversation we talked about it
was like legit it so I'd text her I was
like what the [__]
what is this headline and she was like
I'm sorry like I don't get to do the
headlines my editor does the headlines
and he just like you know he's gonna do
what's gonna drive the most clicks and
like he decided the thing that would
drive the most clicks is talking [__]
about the buyback and like yeah right
like it's like buying my space back and
trying to relaunch it and so I was like
you know that's that's fair but wow what
a shitty moved to pull when you're sort
of given a embargo you and you have all
these other elements of the story that
you could have like used as the lead
shut eye I don't blame I don't blame her
or him because like I think that if you
just because you gave her an embargo
like she should be still say the truth
and say her opinion like and she sent
the hole back if she thinks you're
stupid and what you're doing is stupid
she just because you gave her that she
should say it that's that's true the two
things that I thought were weird were
number one the headline and the story
were so disconnected the story was what
she actually thought in the content
about interview which I posits
frustrating and then the headline was
just something completely different that
was written by a completely different
person and just shows kind of like the
way that
those organizations work the second
thing I thought was kind of whack was
like no heads up like there's a sort of
a human connection to this - right like
if I've done you a favor by giving you
an exclusive piece of news even if
you're gonna write something that you
know I'm not gonna like when you're like
lol this thing is dead Yeah right it's
not gonna come back then you know to
surprise the person I think is an
unnecessary extra slap versus like just
I so disagree with you out I totally
grew at your first point but I don't
agree at your second point which is if
I'm gonna say something negative about
you I'm not gonna give you a heads up
I'm just gonna say it
but let's dum-dum business right you you
cut yourself out then go on forward
right like we had a bunch of other
stories that came out in the coming
years and guess who like never got a
word right her she doesn't cut herself
out for no reason
yeah I mean I think it's a it's
definitely it's a hard thing to balance
and this is why some people like for
example if someone says that they're a
conservative news site well the reason
one of the reasons why they probably
could keep giving conservative people a
good look is so they can get positive
they can yeah so it's definitely hard
but me personally if you if like if
someone comes on this podcast and they
go like oh like will you make me look
good I'm like no I'm not gonna make you
look good I'm not gonna make you look
bad like we'll talk and if I think you
say something dumb I'm just gonna tell
you that's stupid right like I'm not so
III think that I think that if I agree
with that game I've got to suffer the
both the positive and the negative
consequences and the positive
consequences is maybe they're gonna
think I'm great and they'll tell the
truth and also as a quote journalist or
I don't know what you want to call me or
both of us we're gonna like find the
truth but also if someone thinks that
about us and it's negative we got to
live by that yeah I don't mind getting
negative press I did mind the sort of
dissonance and also I don't know like I
just think like it is again bad business
for that person because you burn your
own bridge whereas if you're like hey
look like just wanna let you know like
the articles gonna talk about this and
it's gonna mention this right it's gonna
be there's gonna be some negative parts
which were skeptical about and the
disease cool could have kept that
relationship didn't lost the
relationship maybe doesn't affect me it
affected them maybe telling you ahead of
time is gonna be negative is that
but like if I think that what you say is
[__] I'm gonna say no matter what
yeah that no but nobody wants the other
side right otherwise nobody will read
the [__] if you're not telling you like
it is if you're not telling your actual
opinion then the you know the whole
ecosystem doesn't work but all right
anybody do we have any other ones we
want to talk about yeah well I was gonna
say didn't someone come on the show and
I was like I'm gonna tell this person I
think there's that that that what
they're doing is really stupid and it's
definitely awkward what did that happen
you remember that remember that no man I
think Henry was here oh oh I know what
it was it was the the woman from Everly
well I think she came on with the tests
oh I know I was like I think nutritional
testing is [__] right and you said
it straight to her face
and she answered I'm gonna trying to Pat
myself on the back I'm trying to say
like I don't even remember like did we
call her out you literally said it to
her I kind of facility pot out oh yeah
you did why don't you tell her what you
think about tell her what you were
saying like you know just get it say
yeah definitely set it up it's
definitely awkward like before and after
you're like be nice like I'm definitely
gonna roast you right now it's super
awkward but I think if you do in a
certain way sound that bad it's like
because and they should understand okay
one last thing we but we wouldn't
totally went off the rails here go ahead
well I think what yeah we did go throw
this bike can talk about like beekeeping
and like all kinds of [__] but whatever
so I'm gonna take my hat off and so I
clearly need a haircut my friend Greg
launched this company or a text night
company he just create a website called
you probably need a haircut calm and
it's basically surfing quickly off the
the the quarantine stuff where people
are locked at home everyone's hairs
growing out nobody Erica you shaved a
mohawk what he's doing is he's barbers
who are also out of work they're at home
they can do a zoom consultation and
basically help you cut your own hair and
so that's awesome if you need a haircut
you prop your hair looks good did you
cut it no I'm gonna cut it dude it's
awful it's yeah right now I agree
actually it does look good man but I
looked at it before this hat was on it
and it looked awful so I'm gonna come
I've been cutting my own hair
for ten years now I have I've had the
Clippers I can tell you all that I know
how to do a fade the other day I did
shave it completely bald because I
wanted to feel about Sarah my wife will
help me but for years I would do to my
own and admittedly it probably didn't
look great but I watched videos on how
to like give a fade right and I it's not
that hard but I I've been doing it for
years just because for a long time I was
poor and I didn't want to pay money but
now I do it cuz I'm like aha I don't
want to like to drive they're annoying
to go and plus they always make me take
my headphones out and I'm like well now
I'm bored like you don't understand I
constantly have information going in
through my eyes or my ears and now
you're making me just sit here like yes
and also I just don't want to talk to
them and I'm like I don't know like so
so what I do is I close my eyes and
that's a sign for now but I but I wish
that there was like an app like further
out of certain barbers words like click
like do not talk to me or talk to me
right because like for weird like people
like me I'm like I'm just super I don't
like the confrontation I just don't want
I don't want to talk to leave me alone I
might have a conversation dude I'm like
that a [__] grocery stores you know
Jack Jack Smith he we're like the same
way we go to grocery stores and I'm like
if I don't see what I don't want to if I
don't see what I want to buy even though
they probably have it but in a different
section I don't buy it
I just won't buy it instead of or if I'm
with Sarah be like Sarah we go ask for
this like I don't even want to talk to
anyone right I think a lot of people are
like that yeah add this into Eber where
you could get in and be like yo let's
not let's not do that thing where we
talk yes yes it's awesome
I just don't I'm just like uncomfortable
and I don't want to [__] do it more
Barbara so yeah you know the last thing
to know what they need at Barbara's is
it just need like six different haircuts
for men and you just like give me the
four but they do have that a lot of a
lot don't and you say the same thing
like short on the side a little bit off
the top like everyone's like you just
like show me a picture of like five
people and I'll just point a lot of
barbers don't have that yet or dude it
could be unspoken it's because everybody
just wants short on the side a little
less fluid on top but shorter than it is
currently and you should only have to
say anything if you want some other [__]
like oh I'm going for this other
look I wanna have a look okay then I
told me to tell you about the look but
if not I just want to sit down no words
just do the short on the sides a little
short on top same just like give me like
three options like completely bald like
a whatever the three are and I'll just
point at one of them and by the way just
don't talk to me and once I initiate
conversation and do my eyebrows because
they're getting a little longer I got
long eyebrows everyone knows that that's
number four and also they say like do
you want your you want the back your
neck around it or squared I'm like right
I don't know I don't know there yeah
like I don't see it you you be the judge
right exactly
and I've at one time I asked him I was
like what's the deal with this question
because I don't know and like is there a
difference what's the deal and then
someone told me actually one of the
barbers actually taught me they were
like look if you do square when it
starts to grow back out it's gonna look
shitty so it looked good initially but
then it looks it'll look obviously not
square after it starts to grow out he's
like do the round because then even as
it grows back it's like blends in it's
not so bad dude this sounds like a Larry
David episode like a like so what's the
rounded square what's it like I mean we
tried right so this one went off the
rails
I think people this is gonna hit with
some people so tweet at me and Sean and
let us know if this like random [__]
yeah just tweet like yo stick to the
script if you want us to not go off the
rails as much or just say go off the
rails if you want to sell the goods the
good news is Sean is we don't have to do
that much work to research for next
Tuesday because we I actually had some
stuff to go over
because we got stuck on journalists and
beekeeping and a bunch of stupid
[__] yeah I'm mad again about that
article from 10 years ago now I'm like
still me too I got bad I'm friends with
the woman who I talk to my own friends
with her on Facebook and I like called
her out and it never [__] wins when I
argue people online I'm gonna die end up
looking like it I look like an [__]
and it just doesn't work and I do it all
the time okay
[Music]